[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
wenn unser heutiger Fall ein Buch wäre
dann würde man sicher dieses
schreckliche Foto auf dem Cover sehen
die Hand von Madeleine W das Bild könnte
auch von einer drittklassigen
Gruselgeschichte aus irgend so einem
belo Groschen Roman sein aber unser
heutiger Fall der ist viel zu real um
sich mit Schauer vergleichen aufzuhalten
für Bild hat ihn Chef Reporter Frank
Schneider begleitet und er erklärt auch
was ist mit der Hand auf dem Foto auf
sich hat dieser Fall ist sehr sehr
schrecklich ganz besonders schrecklich
durch ein Foto was ich so in der Art
auch davor und danach nie wieder gesehen
habe und zwar ist es ein Foto aus der
Akte aus der Ermittlungsakte diese
schrecklichen falls der Ermordeten
Madeleine und da sieht man wie ihre Hand
die Nägel nur rot lackiert aus dem
Erdreich rausragt wie so eine Jacke also
die Hand so gebogen und dass ein ganz
schreckliches Foto und da stand daher
dass die junge Frau nachdem sie
bewusstlos gewirkt worden ist mehr oder
weniger lebendig begraben wurde und
unter der Erde einbetoniert wurde dabei
erstickt ist und als das Technische
Hilfswerk zusammen der Mordkommission
die Leiche ausgegraben hat ist denen in
Anführungsstrichen als erstes dieser
Hand entgegengekommen was sogar noch so
aussah als habe sie noch versucht
sozusagen aus ihrem Erdgrab zu entkommen
das ist ein unglaublich schreckliches
Bild aber gleichzeitig zeigt es auch
eben die Grausamkeit und Schrecklichkeit
dieser unglaublichen Tat für die Polizei
löste der Fund im Schrebergarten einen
Vermisstenfall also da verschwand eine
junge Frau und was eben ganz komisch war
sie ließ im junges kleines Kind zurück
drei Jahre alt und da wunderte sich
schon warum lässt ihr Kind zurück und
das sind immer so vermissten Fälle wo
die Polizei natürlich sofort alarmiert
ist es lässt eigentlich keine Mutter
natürlich gibt's auch schon mal Fälle
womit dann Probleme mit Kindern haben
und ihren eigenen Kindern haben aber
hier sah es eben so aus also
unfreiwillig verschwunden und man hatte
dann sehr früh im Rahmen der
Ermittlungen den Verdacht gegen den
Stiefvater weil es dort Probleme gab
weil er als Gewalttätigkeit als
gefährlich galt und auch seine eigene
Frau die Mutter dieses Mädchens panische
Angst vor ihm hatte und das war der
Stiefvater von dieser vermissten
Jungfrau madelen und dann hat die
Polizei mit Hochdruck nach her gefahren
hat versucht auch Bewegungsprofile zu
erstellen aufgrund von Handydaten und
hat dann irgendwann die Spuren diesen
Schrebergarten gefunden und hat dort
dann diese grausame Entdeckung gemacht
bis zu diesem entsetzlichen Mord ist es
ein langer Weg ein Leidensweg Mirko
Madeleine W ist noch ein Baby als
Günther o in das Leben der Familie tritt
der Österreicher ist Küchenhilfe in
Essen nachdem er mit Madeleines Mutter
zusammengekommen ist zieht die Familie
nach Sachsen schon bald ist Madeleines
Mutter von Günter oschwanger und der
kleine Daniel wird in die Familie
geboren
Günther O ist von Anfang an der strenge
Tyrann der herrische bestimmer
spätestens als Madeleine 14 Jahre alt
ist will Günter oh zum ersten Mal Sex
mit ihr erst muss sie ihn oral
befriedigen später vergewaltigt Günther
oder das Mädchen er soll sogar extra ein
Matratzenlager im Keller eingerichtet
haben um sie ungestört missbrauchen zu
können der Perverse droht Madeleine mit
Hausarrest verspricht ihr ein Handy wenn
Sie mit dem schläft über die Jahre
entsteht ein totales
Abhängigkeitsverhältnis der Vater wacht
eifersüchtig über seine Stieftochter die
keinen neben ihm haben soll wenn
Madeleine Freunde mitbringt ekelt der
Vater sie raus
im Jahre 2019 zwingt Günther o die
Familie mit ihm zurück nach Essen zu
ziehen denn Madeleine soll alle soziale
Kontakte abbrechen sie sollen nur für
ihn da sein sechs Jahre lang erträgt
Madeleine dieses Martyrium der
furchtbare Höhepunkt dieses Leidensweges
sie wird von ihrem Stiefvater schwanger
und bekommt ein Baby Tochter Eileen
diese Geschichte bzw dieser Fall ist bis
hierhin schon schwer zu ertragen aber
immerhin kommt jetzt ein Wendepunkt
Madeleine sieht ihre Lage schonungslos
klar und sie hat Angst dass ihr
widerlicher Stiefvater eines Tages auch
ihre Tochter missbrauchen wird eine
erste Flucht misslingt beim zweiten Mal
findet Madeleine Unterschlupfen
Frauenhäusern bekommt schließlich eine
eigene Wohnung in Gelsenkirchen im
August 2012 zeigt sie ihren Stiefvater
wegen sexuellen Missbrauchs an
gleichzeitig verklagt sie ihn auf
Unterhalt für Tochter Eileen Günther O
ist außer sich er hat keinen Zugriff
mehr auf Madeleine er kann sie nicht
mehr missbrauchen und er muss befürchten
dass er für seine jahrelangen Verbrechen
zur Rechenschaft gezogen wird Frank
Schneider ja es wurde natürlich
endgültig noch mal klar in dem Prozess
als man dann auch diesen Stiefvater
gesehen hat der ungepflegt mit
ungewaschenen Haaren mit einem
Bayern-Trikot kann ich mich noch so dran
erinnern das war so absurd in diesem
Gerichtssaal erschienen zusammen mit
seinem Sohn der mit angeklagt war weil
er ihn mehr oder weniger gezogen hat ihn
bei dieser schrecklichen Tat zu helfen
hintergrund war dass der Stiefvater über
viele Jahre mein Leben missbraucht hat
sogar ein Kind mit ihr gezeugt hat und
als Madeleine irgendwann älter war
wollte sie nicht mehr mitmachen sie hat
sich endlich gewehrt sie sind ein
Frauenhaus gegangen und hat gesagt ich
zeig dich an und ich verklagte dich und
das konnte er nicht hinnehmen und er hat
verzweifelt versucht sie zu finden er
hat zum Beispiel übers Internet versucht
unter falschem Fake Profilen als Frau
Kontakt zu ihr aufzunehmen hat dann
seinen Sohn
Bruder von Madeleine vorgeschickt mit
dem sie eigentlich ein gutes Verhältnis
hatte und dieser Lockvogel hat leider
funktioniert und genau darin liegt wie
ich finde eine zusätzliche bittere
Tragik in diesem Fall eigentlich haben
Frauenhäuser viel Erfahrung darin Täter
wie Günther o von ihren Schützlingen
fernzuhalten und das funktioniert auch
in diesem Fall aber der von ihm gewählte
Umweg über seinen Sohn der funktioniert
Daniel schreibt Madeleines Anwältin dass
er sich als Bruder wieder Kontakt zu ihr
wünscht und die Juristin leitet den
Brief an Sie weiter und so wird der
Kontakt wieder hergestellt die beiden
tauschen Handynummern aus noch mal Frank
Schneider der Bruder hat dann gesagt er
möchte sich mit dir mal treffen am Essen
Hauptbahnhof mal wieder wenigstens reden
auch wenn sie Frauenhaus ist und dann
hat er sie zu einem Auto gelockt und in
diesem Auto saß der Stiefvater und dort
hat er sie festgehalten die kam aus dem
Auto nicht mehr raus und dann sind in
diesen Schrebergarten gefahren und dort
hat er sie dann geschlagen verprügelt
und schließlich dann gewirkt und
geknebelt dass sie erstickt ist aber sie
war eben noch nicht tot und hinterher
die Obduktion ergeben dass sie offenbar
dann lebendig zwar bewusstlos aber
lebendig begraben worden ist und man
weiß nicht ob sie möglicherweise noch
mal unter der Erde wach geworden ist und
hat ein Beton drauf gegossen und hat
dann noch ganz ganz absurd drei
Lebensbäume auf dieses frische Grab
gepflanzt in seinem Schrebergarten und
hat gedacht damit ist der Fall für ihn
erledigt
[Musik]
ich finde es furchtbar dass er es
tatsächlich geschafft hat seine
Stieftochter umzubringen und es wird
noch eine Rolle spielen dass Madeleines
Halbbruder Daniel nicht dabei war er
erklärt später glaubhaft dass er bald
nach der Ankunft im Schrebergarten
wieder weggefahren ist dank der anzeigen
muss die Polizei nicht lange nach einem
Verdächtigen suchen und auch das frische
Grab in der Schrebergartensiedlung ist
nicht besonders schwer auszumachen und
so kommt es bald nach der vermissten
Meldung im Fall Madeleine zur Szene die
wir schon am Anfang geschildert haben
mit Unterstützung des Technischen
Hilfswerkes wird im Garten Erde
ausgehoben und der Beton aufgebrochen
und wie eine grausige Anklage erhebt
sich Madeleines Hand aus dem Grund kein
halbes Jahr nach dem Mord im Sommer 2014
stehen Vater und Sohn vor Gericht in
Essen für Bild berichtet Frank Schneider
von diesem Verfahren also im Prozess was
ganz wichtig dass der Bruder irgendwann
auch durch die Beratung seines Anwaltes
ausgepackte der hat sich auch von dem
Vater bloß gesagt und hat dann gesagt
ich habe nicht gewusst was der vorhat er
hat immer nur davon gesprochen er will
eine Aussprache er will dass sie die
Anzeige zurücknimmt von einer Tötung war
nie die Rede das habe ich nicht gewusst
und er hat auch behaupten das konnte man
ihm auch das Gegenteil nicht beweisen
die Spuren sprachen sogar eher dafür
dass er auch wirklich die Wahrheit sagt
der Bruder er ist dann vom
Schrebergarten Weg er hätte natürlich
Sachen die Richter auch sich denken
können was möglicherweise dort passiert
aber er hat halt nur gedacht der Vater
will sie unter Druck setzen dass sie die
Anzeige zurücknimmt damit ihm keine
Strafe droht und ist dann von dem
Schrebergarten weg und dann hat der
Stiefvater sie eben getötet und da war
er schon nicht mehr dabei er hat dann
ausgepackt Günter oh macht in dem
Verfahren den ziemlich durchsichtigen
Versuch den Mord als Unfall darzustellen
Günther oh sei sehr wütend gewesen und
habe eine Flasche an die Wand werfen
wollen aber Madeleines Kopf getroffen
der Richter glaubt ihm nicht er sagte
der Ort heißt Begründung Günther oh
degradierte Madeleine zum reinen Objekt
entsorgte ihre Leiche wie Gartenabfall
das Gericht verurteilt ur zu Lebens
verhaft erstellt außerdem die besondere
Schwere der Schuld fest das bedeutet der
Täter kommt nach 15 Jahren nicht frei
Sohn Daniel bekommt vier Jahre wegen
Freiheitsberaubung mit Todesfolge weil
er eben seine Stiefschwester in die
Falle lockte und wie geht es wohl der
kleinen Eileen Frank Schneider was aus
dem Kind geworden ist hat das Jugendamt
natürlich nicht mitgeteilt nach unserem
Kenntnisstand ist es dann damals zur
Adoption freigegeben worden hat eben
hoffentlich eine Familie gefunden wo es
ihm gut geht weil Mutter tot und Vater
gleichzeitig Opa in Anführungsstrichen
Stiefopa sitzt zum Glück immer noch im
Gefängnis der Stiefvater hat er damals
lebenslang bekommen zusätzlich noch
wurde die besondere Schwere der Schuld
festgestellt dass es nicht ganz
unwichtig weil es in Deutschland so lang
läufig heißt lebenslang sind 15 Jahre
das ist hier aber auf gar keinen Fall so
diese Täter die diese besondere Schwere
der Schuld noch bekommen können einen
Antrag aufhaften Entlassung erst nach
vielen vielen Jahren stellen das heißt
die sitzen in der Regel mindestens 25
Jahre kann man sagen das heißt der Vater
wird noch sehr lange hinter Gittern
sitzen der Stiefvater und Mörder von
Madeleine der Bruder hat damals nur vier
Jahre bekommen wegen sogenannter
Freiheitsberaubung mit Todesfolge weil
er das ja nicht wusste wie er glaub was
versichert hat dass sie getötet werden
sollte und der ist dann auch nach zwei
Drittel der Strafe der Haft Verbüßung
auf freien fußgesetz und dass der heute
macht oder so der wird wahrscheinlich
ein neues Leben angefangen haben
möglicherweise auch mit seiner Mutter
die sich von diesem grauenhaften Täter
ja auch losgesagt hat in solchen Fällen
interessiert mich wirklich sie denn die
Sicht von einer Mutter darauf ist
besonders auch in diesem Fall hat sie
den Missbrauch
ignoriert oder vielleicht sogar geduldet
weil ich meine ein Matratzenlager im
Keller in dem dein Mann mit deiner
Tochter verschwindet das tschuldigung
das kann man nicht nicht gewusst haben
aber Madeleines Mutter Birgit Biggi
genannt die ist an diesem Leben wohl
längst vorher zerbrochen sie soll stark
getrunken haben nahm valium und galt als
psychisch krank bleibt nach all den
Jahren des Missbrauchs die Frage ob es
irgendein Behörden Versagen gab ob eine
Schulabteilung oder ein Jugendamt der
einschreiten können aber offenbar wurde
die Familie nicht überprüft Günter oh
war mehrfach vorbestraft auch das gehört
zur Geschichte in seiner Akte sind
aufgeführt Körperverletzung Bedrohung
Beleidigung Nötigung Sachbeschädigung
Urkundenfälschung Vergewaltigung
Widerstand gegen Polizeibeamte
Widerstand gegen Vollstreckungsbeamte
und auf die Straßenverkehrsgefährdung er
kommt oft mit Bewährung davon wir haben
Frank Schneider gefragt ob nach
Madeleines Anzeigen Fehler gemacht
wurden eigentlich nicht weil man hat ja
die Tochter unterstützt sie ist auch uns
Frauenhaus der Fehler war der Klassiker
was man natürlich Frauen immer ja
empfiehlt wenn sie in Frauenhäuser gehen
alle alten Kontakte abbrechen Handy weg
neue Handynummer nicht mehr die alten
Profile bedienen und ähnliches und den
Fehler hat sie halt gemacht wie junge
Menschen sind die über Social Media
unterwegs sind hat sie auch diesen
Fehler gemacht auch wenn das schon neun
Jahre her ist sie hat dann eben auch zu
dem Bruder Kontakt aufgenommen was man
natürlich aber irgendwie auch verstehen
kann zu dem hatte sie eigentlich noch
eine Bindung den mochte sie und der
Bruder ist aber von dem Vater eben auch
unter solche Gewalt gesetzt worden und
unter solche Drogen gesetzt worden dass
der dann irgendwann mitgemacht hat und
sich dem nicht wiedersetzen konnte und
im Endeffekt war das der Fehler von
Madeleine dass sie es nicht geschafft
hat die Brücken komplett abzubrechen sie
war in Köln in einem Frauenhaus dort
hätte er sie nie finden können der
Stiefvater aber sie ist dann zurück nach
Essen gefahren hat sie mit dem Bruder
getroffen und das war leider der
lokvogel
das ist das üble an der Geschichte
Madeleine wusste dass ihr perverser
Stiefvater ihr Todfeind war der gegen
den sie sich wehren musste der bestraft
werden musste aber ihrem Bruder hat sie
so weit vertraut dass sie sich trafen
wenn wir nicht mal den trauen können die
wir mögen was bleibt dann ja auch das
gehört leider zu Wahrheit dieses Falls
Daniel ihr Bruder scheint auch eine
tragische Figur in dieser Geschichte zu
sein daher offensichtlich von seinem
Vater manipuliert und unter Druck
gesetzt wurde und so dieses grausame
Verbrechen und seine Schwester erst
ermöglicht hat
zumal ihm das wahrscheinlich in dem
Moment nicht mal klar war was er da
gerade tut
wir können nur hoffen und das wünsche
ich dir wirklich sehr dass die Kleine
Eileen also die Tochter von Madeline dem
Ort Opfer ein schönes Zuhause hat und
ohne solche Schatten groß werden kann da
stimme ich dir voll und ganz zu und
damit sind wir am Ende unserer heutigen
Episode die Fakten für diesen Fall haben
Frank Schneider und Stefan Netze
zusammengetragen wertvolle Informationen
gab es auch in Artikeln der Süddeutschen
Zeitung und vom Stern Aufnahme und
schnittproduktion durch weight watch
Studios München bis zur nächsten Episode
euer Mirko und eure Tunnel